why does everybody keep on hiring me all
of my work is shit hey Malcolm hey
critic did you know one third of the
world's oranges are grown in Brazil what
an odd thing to say yeah I guess it's my
quirk oranges okay I'm gonna go shoot
the review now as you know there are two
types of people in this world those who
believe that evil is good and those who
believe that evil is evil
Tamara why are you spilling that sloppy
unfocused philosophy
I hear you whispering plan on stealing
something why is nobody talking right
today plan on murdering me in my sleep
what no wait a minute it's affecting me
now around 85% of oranges are produced
for juice
oranges are tomato she knows as well as
filled with people who do not understand
the ramifications without you here I
might as well make you suffer although
really don't know why the second boys
before doing 3d I have years I think of
shoes tensioner a sealant my god I know
what this is I know what's going on here
this is
the Shama rising
well a camera we can all get up and
action sit close to as you know show
seen the warning signs the bad monotone
acting the dialogue that makes no sense
whatsoever and Europe lobbing all of
this for some reason
who knows who will be next I'm not
careful all of us could end up like the
actors from the happening
based on a title so lazily vague that
the film does everything in its power to
justify it is something happening in a
few states this really be happening
whatever is happening is happening
population happily happily happening
happening happening happening the
happening is garnered a reputation as
one of the most entertaining ly bad
movies ever made yep right up there with
the room troll - and give it time for
years we've made references to this
trainwreck but I've never given it a
full review analyzing why it's so bad
it's actually kind of amazing so let's
take a look to figure out what how and
well we'll never figure out why it's
Gemma 1 this is the happening it starts
off in New York as two women do what
Shyamalan thinks two women do read a
book at the same time I forgot where
you're at the place where the killer's
meet to decide what to do with the
crippled girl oh that's right good thing
I was reading the exact same sentence as
the crowd suddenly realizes they're on
The Truman Show there well that's what I
would do if I found out I was in the
happening just down the street doesn't
seem to be much better right in the
Kensie film oh no not pork rice
Mackenzie but it's raining men as
everybody's apparently committing
suicide or having a hell of a time
catching road runners this leads us to
our main character Elliot played by Mark
Wahlberg look I don't know if you guys
have heard about this article the New
York Times about honey bees vanishing if
you have not burst out into laughter yet
from the mere delivery of that line then
you are watching the greatest drama
you've ever seen in your life no
seriously where's the real performance
that can't be for real
scary huh I mean this is Mark Wahlberg a
pretty damn good actor but I'm not
kidding he does the whole performance
like this it's like he's on a 2:00 a.m.
infomercial look I don't know if you
guys have heard about this article in
The New York Times about honeybees
vanishing scary huh well now you can
track him down with our new honeybee
tracker order now and you'll also
receive a free Sam Wow
as we quickly discover he's not that
great a teacher either Jake you don't
have an opinion should be more interest
in science Jake you know why it'll make
you talk like a Luke Skywalker of his
wine eNOS levels were pushed to 20
because your face is perfect now if you
were interested in science you would
know facts like the human nose and ears
grow a fraction of an inch each ear to a
perfect balance of features now it might
not look so perfect five years from now
take an interest in science yes take an
interest in science after I literally
insulted your face hey Suze you
interested in science that's because
you're a slut in typical Shyamalan style
she comes up with the laziest answer
worded in a way that's trying to sound
important an act of nature and we'll
never fully understand it and that's how
you got a D in this class kid ice answer
Jake all right nice answer Jake that
science will come up with some reason to
put in the books I mean we will fail to
acknowledge that there are forces at
work beyond our understanding
yeah great science teacher there
something something something magic like
all great scholars he acknowledges that
science is just a temporary solution for
the real answer which is just shrinking
your arm saying I don't know the dark
look at your eyes mm-hmm nice principal
what can we do for you you can clear out
your desk asshole what do you think I'm
gonna say after that so all the teachers
are forced to abandon their students
typical protocol as they're all gathered
in one room to be told about the crisis
sweeping America Central Park was just
hit by what seems to be a terrorist
attack it's some kind of airborne
chemical toxin that's been released in
and around the park there appears to be
an event happening okay that's a tragedy
or an emergency and event is a sale at
Target you know for teachers you're not
very good with words
Central Park that's kind of yeah
terrorists rarely go after landmarks
with lots of people this means all the
students are let out early what are the
rules of scientific investigation
identified variables design experiment
careful observation and measurement
interpretation of experimental data
Jesus Christ said don't forget to recite
the first two chapters of Moby Dick call
me Ishmael some years ago never mind how
long precisely having little or no money
in my purse mother just call my cell
again she's hysterical
so while Wilbur's friend played by John
Leguizamo establishes his strange quirk
being his mother
I threw some figures at it told her the
probability of something happening in
Philadelphia is very low hey you stand
out now we're introduced to all played
by Zooey Deschanel she leaving you I
didn't say that it's just talk okay just
relax please
oh no we're at the Schemmel on stage
where critic as you know Jim and I have
decided that we're in love even though
we have no chemistry at all
whoop-dee-doo no it's bad
revering trouble in our relationship we
fear will never be a couple again no no
that's just the shovel ontake he always
has a couple that's going through
problems but it's omni's we gotta get
together in the air
no pretty as you know this is pretty
serious we're having some incredibly
vague problems that only a supernatural
event can fix you to be quiet
Porges look just stay in there try to
use logic and for the love of God don't
be quirky but quirky is charming now Jim
it's awkward
600 as you'd imagine Deschanel's acting
is about as bad as everyone else's but
there is a certain alien freakiness
about her facial expressions yeah she
looks like this throughout the entire
film it's like in every shot she
realized she shit her pants and she
wants nobody to realize it her delivery
isn't much better either it makes you
kill yourself just when you thought
there couldn't be any more people like
me invented how do you even direct
somebody to say a line that way all
right Zoe I want you to act like you're
deaf but in saying this line you're
hearing yourself for the first time and
you don't enjoy what you sound like it
makes you kill yourself just when you
thought there couldn't be any more evil
like be invented that was definitely a
thing so Wahlberg says he'll meet
Deschanel and Leguizamo at the train
station
where's Alma restroom
hey Julian why the hell'd you shoot it
like that we trying to make her look
like a stalker hey Julian are you doing
hanging in there mm-hm
typical seven-year-old response hanging
in there still looking for a job got
those bills to pay
it's hard being a single mother so well
on the train they're being told that the
panic is spreading yo Casey Boston got
hit too would you do that a friend from
work what about a bit Christ that
College grew who took theater is a
blow-up class is acting better than you
the train stops suddenly it looks like
they're kicking everybody off what do
you mean where are we Philbert
Pennsylvania does anybody know where
that is
hey why would you just stop you know if
you could take the whining of a dog and
convert it into a language and beat this
performance sorry she whispers to us why
she'd get scared we're so much the same
Jess I don't like to show my emotions
either yeah - cool wall burn from
earlier done with a capital M mm and the
danger still seems to be spreading as
one man says farewell to arms in the
lion's den mother of god what kind of
terrorists are these there's such hairy
and yellow terrorists they must be from
the Land of Oz so everybody takes off as
the virus seems to be right in their
neighborhood and Lake Lezama decides to
leave his daughter with Wahlberg so he
can go back for his wife because things
always turn out well for people who do
that right she's gonna be a lot safer
with you I have to go I got her to take
my daughter's hand wish me
oh I'm sorry why don't you find another
couple to look after the daughter you're
lovingly abandoning you're welcome
asshole there's a car very good Zoey now
can you tell which one's the plane so
Wahlberg's gang gets a ride with a guy
who runs a plant nursery poorly located
next to a nuclear power plant why do I
get the feeling this is all streaming
from there
Oh mr. Birds I'm afraid I caused a
happening continue it now we're trapped
in an M night Shyamalan film and not one
of the good ones either of them
they're collecting a few things before
they go when this bit of strangeness is
sad we're packing hot dogs for the road
you know hot dogs get a bad rap got a
cool shape dick got protein you like hot
dogs right
brought to you by hot dogs want to be
less cautious about where your meat
comes from the chicken McNuggets hot
dogs I think I know what's causing this
you do
it's the plans wait what it's the plans
they can release chemicals Wow
that's actually the twist of the movie
it's plant I know it seems like I'm
giving some stuff away early here but
the movie is giving some stuff away
earlier here so what do I care
we're not even 1/3 into the film and you
already gave away the big twist you like
hot dogs don't you follow by that do you
need to go back to film 101 I think most
people know this you don't give away the
twist before you give away the twist you
would open Citizen Kane with it's a sled
it's kind of a no-brainer Critic as you
know we think we know it's cause the
channelization okay what
all no we're not doing that as you know
it makes a lot of sense if they use lead
paint no even for a parody we're not
doing that you know or just typically
contain ten segments maybe one of them
contains generalization fine make a
connection to that but we're not doing
goddamn walls how we're supposed to make
orange is the twist I don't know what
the freaking giving tree could be an
antagonist in a movie why can't oranges
now get cracking
you guys like gorgeous right
you